I want to dig in a little more
specifically to the recount issue that's
going on I told you at the beginning of
the show that we have recounts being
asked for Jill Stein raising millions of
dollars Hillary Clinton campaign saying
they are supportive of the recounts in
Wisconsin we also are talking about
Pennsylvania where the deadline is today
and Michigan where the deadline is on
Wednesday pre recount okay the recount
in Wisconsin is not set to start until
the end of the week this is unbelievable
pre recount three Wisconsin precincts
have already revised their vote totals
in out a game II County I want to be
super precise here to communicate to you
what's going on Donald Trump's official
victory in Wisconsin was twenty seven
thousand two hundred fifty seven votes
based on these precinct revisions that
lead has dropped to twenty two thousand
five hundred twenty-five votes
you might say oh okay that's a little
under five thousand votes what's the big
deal that represents an evaporation into
thin air of over 17 percent of Donald
Trump's margin of victory just poof we
we put the numbers in incorrectly and
there goes seventeen point something
percent of trumps victory let's add to
this the reality that Wisconsin was
number one a more surprising victory for
Donald Trump given the history of
Wisconsin over the last several election
cycles number two Wisconsin was one of
the states in which the exit polls
differed from the reported vote counts
by more than the margin of error also by
the way in Donald Trump's favor
Wisconsin saw Trump losing in the exit
polls by three point nine percent
winning in the official results by 0.9
percent meaning that there was a nearly
five-point swing a four point eight
point swing from the exit polls to the
reported results I've been talking about
this for weeks every time I talk about
it a lot of people ask me why why aren't
corporate media outlets talking about
this well they have no incentive to talk
about this whatsoever I want to show you
a quote from a DES game e with Scott
and officials to ABC News explaining
what the hell happened what explains the
evaporation instantly of 17% of Donald
Trump's win while they said quote in
order to give election returns to the
outta gamy County Clerk's office as
quickly as possible
the chief inspector added together the
votes from the election machine tapes an
error was made while keying the numbers
on the calculator during this process
resulting in an incorrect the number of
votes reported on election night ok well
that I mean it's an explanation but
let's apply a little bit of more
scrutiny to it what they're saying is
it's a coincidence that in all three
precincts where there were errors the
errors exclusively favored Donald Trump
three separate precincts just an
accident an innocent keying error and it
was an error that in all three cases
went in Donald Trump's favor interesting
very very interesting who keyed them in
from the three precincts many more
questions here and I want to remind you
17% of Donald Trump's victory in
Wisconsin has evaporated before the
recount even starts so you'd better
believe that we're going to be watching
what happened there